russian energy giant gazprom has
announced more cuts to gas deliveries to
germany via its nord stream one pipeline
from wednesday gas flows will be halved
to around 20 of normal capacity the
russian state-owned firm blames the move
on technical problems with one of the
pipeline's turbines different turbine to
the one blamed for the existing
reduction in flows the german government
says there is no technical problem and
moscow is playing a duplicitous game the
kremlin denies it's deliberately
limiting europe's gas supplies in
response to sanctions
russia is not interested in stopping gas
supplies to europe
russia is a responsible supplier of gas
and whoever says what whether it be the
european commission european capital
cities or the united states of america
russia was is and remains a country that
in no small way guarantees europe's
energy security
and not just verbally
but the fact
are the factor
well let's bring in thomas o'donnell who
is an energy and geopolitical analyst
thanks a lot for joining us on dw
business we just heard from dmitry
peskov there saying russia helps europe
with its energy security but is there
any doubt left that russia is using
energy as a weapon against germany in
the eu
well
thanks for having me today rob um
you know
things were quite intense between
germany and the rest of europe for a
number of years the rest of europe was
saying germany was sort of opening the
fortress door to the trojan horse and
here we have it
we're very dependent on russian gas and
now the russians are weaponizing it
to support their war of aggression in
ukraine it can't be put any any simpler
so basically
germany's allies have been warning them
that this was going to happen and and
and it has happened but this is what now
germany and the eu has to deal with uh
the eu has agreed today to a plan on how
it's going to reduce its reliance on
russian gas and indeed its overall
reliance on gas this winter but i mean
is there a realistic prospect of germany
just ending exports of gas to the eu all
together this year
no
germany has a very difficult situation
much more difficult than say a country
like spain or portugal who installed
many lng terminals years ago
um
yeah in germany uh the minister quite
rightly mr halbach robert halbach says
we have to increase now storage by 75 85
95 percent september october november
but the head of the transmission uh
system the gas transmission system mr
klaus muta has said at 40 he said this a
couple days ago at 40 percent
uh supplies coming through north stream
one is not possible now with 20 it won't
be possible furthermore we have an over
dependence on wind that was not thought
through there is no real grid scale
storage although halbach wants to agree
to bring on massively coal to replace
the gas that's being used to generate
electricity which is sort of a waste we
need to save that for heating in winter
and for industry
turns out the wind's not blowing and the
rhine is low the water you can't bring
in enough coal and so we're burning gas
right now when we're supposed to be
storing it to produce electricity in
germany at a higher rate than last year
so it's a very difficult situation i
can't see how there won't be rationing
in germany and a number of other
countries this winter with you know
grave consequences this is putin's plan
to divide to undermine the solidarity of
europe in support of ukraine it's an
economic war
we've got this latest cut from 40 to 20
but it only resumed at 40
last week
i'm just wondering why has moscow
decided to do this this week and didn't
just do it from the start last week when
they they turned the pipeline back on
well you know you're asking me to kind
of guess what's going on in mr putin's
head but i i think i can rely you know
i think i could say that you know
putin can afford to cut off the gas
completely at any time the amount of
money he earns from gas is substantial
but far less than from exports of oil
three four five times less depending on
if you're talking about gdp
or you know state revenues so he can
afford to play games with gas on the
other hand
europe is most dependent on russian gas
more so than oil there's alternatives
for oil that can come by sea there's no
alternatives for other pipelines really
in the short term so this is its maximum
pressure instead of turning it off
completely he's playing a game he's
setting trying to set people against
each other and right now i'd say his
tactical aim is to prevent the storage
from being filled so that when he does
likely cut it off in winter it'll have
maximum effect and that that's how i see
this this current game